qué tal Raúl te gusta Uruguay te gustan
los charrúas así los terceros en la
eliminatoria Sudamericana van a jugar
aquí en la apertura del grupo H contra
Corea del Sur Ese es el education City
este año ya tenemos las alineaciones
confirmadas para este encuentro Uruguay
que saldrá con Sergio Rocher en portería
línea de cuatro en defensa para Olivera
godín Jiménez Cáceres en el centro del
campo Matías vecino acompañado de
Rodrigo Betancourt y de quizás para
muchos el mejor jugador de Europa por
estos momentos Federico Valverde
adelante está en Luis Suárez Darwin
Núñez de Liverpool y la sorpresa de esta
alineación Facundo pellistre El joven
delantero de 20 años del Manchester
United me acabo de cruzar con El loco
Abreu leyenda del fútbol uruguayo y
destacaba la inclusión de Este joven
delantero que viene con pocos minutos y
la acaba de ganar la titularidad a
Edison caven y que se encuentra en
plenas condiciones físicas pero
finalmente ha sido feliz El Elegido para
este encuentro por parte de Corea del
Sur destacamos la inclusión en el 11
oficial de humanson El delantero del
tottenham hotspurs quien venía con una
fractura en su rostro finalmente va a
ser titular para alegría de los locales
el combinado asiático que es el
combinado de ese continente con más
representaciones en la copa mundo es el
único equipo que no ha ganado este
certamen y que más tiempo ha venido a
esta cita mundialista mucha expectativa
aquí por ver el debut de Uruguay en un
mundial que no Nos está dejando buenos
resultados para los representantes
latinoamericanos representantes
latinoamericanos hasta el momento
solamente Ecuador ha conseguido ganar en
ese certamen Juan es así y pues le
pregunto del partido que acabamos de ver
el de Suiza Camerún
partido válido por el grupo G Victoria
para Suiza por 1 a 0 con un gol de brel
en bolo jugador del Mónaco que nació en
Camerún el juega con Suiza pero nació en
Calderón de aquí de ahí de que hoy
cuando marcó ese único tanto de la
Victoria para los helvéticos pidiera
perdón a la afición cuando marcó ese
tanto que terminó dándole los primeros
Tres puntos a su equipo ese es el grupo
de Brasil la canaleña que debuta este
mismo jueves También en esta copa mundo
de Qatar lo hace en el último turno de
la noche a las 10 hora local contra la
Serbia de blajovich